[Music]
guys csgo is a game balanced on a mere
thread one little tweak from Daddy valve
and [ __ ] can get it a hand real fast so
what is the most broken gun in the
history of Counter Strike global
Offensive well from pistols that were
better than rifles to the coming of the
augggh pocalypse here are the top 10
most broken guns in all of csgo
starting us off at number 10 is the pre
nerf op now we know what this one is a
bit of a contentious one but after so
many years the benefit of hindsight has
shown us just how broken the pre nerf
awfully was you remember before they did
things to much well one guy with
increased movement speed and offer could
single-handedly change the outcome of
the game regardless of what opposition
came their way we witnessed the true
potential of the pre nerf Arctic warfare
police in the hands of French superstar
Kenny s we can see where he's looking
now just hit the shot barely on himself
finds the second one Kenny the noscope
kenny ass sights it down and tightened
they managed to get another round and
although it's not like the 2015 rework
made the gun by any means unusable it
just wasn't the same just ask any thank
you the number 9 spot we have the run
and gun update valve is philosophy when
it comes to updating csgo seems like
they're always trying to balance a land
a problem rather than addressing it
directly and in 2015 valve changed the
SMGs with the hope of tackling the tech
9 this update allowed for players to run
around like absolute maniacs popping
in the process and creating an
environment where you could run in gun
in a game where you're really not
supposed to it's cool to hear that and
then see it kind of going to play let's
go see the mac-10 just rushing right up
through the ball it's off and because
all alone and that's washed out with a
third coming in at the number eight spot
is the 2014 iteration of the cz-75 in
the earlier days of csgo this gun had it
all in fact maybe it had a little bit
too much you could pull it out in almost
any situation
with incredible running accuracy a high
rate of fire and incredible damage this
pistol made any eco a nightmare all
while costing just five hundred dollars
with a $300 kill reward of a generation
molotovs in set peace out shroud has let
them all pass
if there was any gun that could get you
back into the game in a single round
well this was probably it
series 4d atomizer that's what I'm
talking about
noisy cricket hey okay no no come on man
you get a series four of the atomizer I
get a little [ __ ] cricket okay the
number seven spot on our list is the
balance change that basically put the m4
out of business at least for a while
we're talking about the 2019 hog for the
bulk of csgo Spach history the odd was
left relatively untouched and was always
seen to be well balanced because of its
price but with one price change CS goes
metagame would be turned completely on
its head the odd cat all the tools to
dominate the game and when it became a
little more affordable it did box he's
gonna get the shot easy but sip is left
and out of all the players you wouldn't
want a one versus one against maybe sip
is the old food somehow they didn't even
take anything in a matter of months the
augggh became the rifle of choice for
the CTS it's single-handedly made the
games he decided and just when players
were adapting valve nerfed it you kiss
your mother with that mouth
it's called you kids call you kiss your
mother with that [ __ ] mouth on its way
to the six barn on our list is the 2017
UMP in October of 2014
valve rolled out an SMG update which
allowed for 20% more armor penetration
across the board at first this went
relatively unnoticed with teams opting
for the tried-and-true bill deal or
FAMAS
but once teams started to catch on it
became the force by dream and the bane
of any full by
boy device gets all for all of the ump
and he's got money as Jia B takes down J
KS you hate to see that
what are those Neanderthals up to don't
they know I'm busy spoiling myself
the number 5 spot we welcome you to 5
heaven picking up with a tec-9 left off
the five-seven grew to prominence as an
essential eco weapon which would
dismantle any foe by in its path pretty
much taken out of their pockets
incredibly accurate and incredibly
mobile this pistol could do it all and
in many cases could go toe-to-toe with
these stronger weapons in the game the
only caveat that they have that strategy
and that's no more can opener is it
gonna be the classic way to close it out
on an eco heat go with the 3k make it 4
with the 5-7 and what is that what is
that 5-7 left more than a few players
frustrated without helpless they were at
the site of heaven and if you were one
of them well we're sorry
[Music]
taking the number-4 spot on our list is
the gun that forged a new meaning for
the phrase eco round that's right it's
the 2015 technology well once again just
being eco is he about to pull up the
Alamo we've got three from behind quad
can he find a fourth he gets the fourth
he's odd for the eighth in 2014 Val put
a buff on the innocent little pistol
which drastically increased the accuracy
in almost all situations we're talking
standing still running or even jumping
this position he's looking to jump up on
the sky and he's gonna do it there oh
what get right tag it down defy spin air
with the tec-9 devices going to be
furious
once team's caught on the tec-9 era
began every round became a threat to
lose with 5 players being able to take a
site in mere seconds for minimal
economic investment although oh my god
he gets another killer in now clocked
running out 7 seconds all of my star
looking for the kill 5 second it goes
and it's gonna be the round done the gun
did get nerfed in 2015 but it wouldn't
be the last time we saw a pistol
dominate the game one tapping its way to
the number three spot is the automatic
pistol that pissed everybody off from
pros to Silver's in 2018 the cz 75 and
somehow they get it all the way through
rain picking up to big kills that's
happy coming through the cset 75 he's
only got four bullets left and Nico now
all alone he goes down happy finds the
last kill with just four bullets
unbelievable performance coming out of
him it's dad's made the gun essentially
a mini rifle where you could one tap
people rushing on to a site or be
patient with multiple taps at farther
range and despite the community outcry
this meta would dominate the game for
months can you ask him only one question
and I believe many of them wants to know
when are you going to nerf the cz-75 ah
at the runner-up spot we have the coming
of the augggh pocalypse
for a very brief period in 2014 valve
sought to diversify the toolkit of the
CTS so they bought the OGG with
increased fire rate and decreased recoil
combine that with the scope and this
created a monstrosity which tortured the
csgo community for seven hellish days
known as OGG week
taking the top spot on our list is the
brief period of time where csgo
turned into the Wild West in a game with
ak-47s and m4s and ops all it took was
one unbalanced six-shooter to throw the
entire game on its head are you [ __ ]
introduced in the 2015 winter update the
r8 revolver broke everything on launch
it was a hand cannon that was incredibly
cheap and could destroy your opponent
with one shot in most areas for just a
couple of days we all got to be Cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
well guys that was our list what do you
think do we get it right what is your
personal most hated most broken gun in
csgo honestly when you're as bad as I am
they all seem pretty broken thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and bring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else
get up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages